just some breaking news now to bring you
from Sudan news of a ceasefire first the
rsf that's the paramilitary group the
rapid support forces have announced an
extension of the ceasefire in Sudan for
72 hours starting from Midnight uh local
time tonight that's in it another 72
hour ceasefire extension but no
confirmation yet from the Army who of
course they are fighting regarding that
ceasefire we'll bring you more on that
as we get it but we're also hearing an
update from the foreign office too that
the UK government is to offer an
evacuation flight to help British
Nationals leave port Sudan that's in the
east of the country around 500 miles
away from the capital Khartoum where
people have been gathering in the hope
of an evacuation while the UK government
has now confirmed that they are to offer
an evacuation flight to British
Nationals from Sudan and they are urging
British Nationals if they want to be on
one of those flights to travel to the
British evacuation handling Center at
Port Sudan international airport
tomorrow before midday local time to
allow for processing that's the UK
government evacuating more British
citizens uh tomorrow we'll bring you
more on that as we get it